Today we're going to be looking at item number scp-239 object class Keter special
Containment procedures
Scp-239 is to be kept within a one room cell furnished with one bed one
EKG machine and one IV to be filled with a pentobarbital mixed with
To be refilled daily
under no circumstances is
Scp-239 to be removed from her containment area at any given time
The walls of the cell are to be coated in a Teleca lead alloy
Only class 2 personnel are allowed any contact with scp-239 at any time all personnel guarding
Scp-239 s containment area are to be equipped with Teleco headgear
The subjects proper name is something. I'm gonna leave to a text-to-speech program
See who doses demo started?
Under absolutely no condition should the subject ever be awakened
Any personnel found attempting to awaken the subject will be immediately terminated?
Description
Scp-239 appears to be an 8 year old girl 1 meter in height and 20 kilograms in weight
Subject has shoulder-length blond hair upon closer inspection the subjects eyes shimmer a gray green shade
Subject seems to emit a previously undiscovered form of radiation, which has been named?
These waves seem to be harmless in low concentrations, but in higher concentrations, they could breakdown matter on a subatomic level
Scp-239
Seemingly has the ability to do whatever she expresses a will to do
but simply the subject can do anything that she truly wants to do on a basal psychological level as
Long as she is conscious
Fortunately, she only seems to be able to affect herself and her immediate surroundings therefore if she can see it
She can change it
It would not be the most prudent course of action
However to try to test how powerful she can be she seems to be able to create an effect living matter
for example when a d-class personnel
Accidentally caused her harm. She simply wished him away
Fortunately when the subject was made to feel guilty for what she had done she wished him back
Scp-239 self-preservation instinct makes her virtually invincible while he's conscious subject skin cannot be punctured by anything
excepting SCP 148
As a method of controlling the subjects ability she has been told that she is a witch
This besides improving morale greatly makes her believe that she is unable to use her abilities outside of a pre-approved list of spells
Given to her by the foundation this will hopefully prevent any and all attempted escapes
However, the subject is to be kept calm at all times to prevent any subconscious wish of harm to herself or others
Origin
Scp-239 came to the attention of the foundation very soon after her birth
Approximately three hours after the subjects birth
Hospital was destroyed by an unexplained explosion the press was informed that it was due to a gas leak
SCP teams were dispatched shortly to search the site for any abnormalities
The only living person they were able to locate was
scp-239
For the next eight years the subject was raised under SCP care as of 20
Subjects is to be kept in a medically induced coma until further notice this decision was made by
Scp-239 is permanently contained inside 17
Note from dr. Dated the 26th of December
Who the hell thought it will be a good idea to tell her about Santa Claus
And then tell her that it was just a story
Now we have another potential SCP to deal with but we can't catch him because he is quote magic
Dr.. Ade clefts report
My analysis of the situation has led me to the conclusion that
Scp-239 is an unacceptable containment and security risk although several proposals have been made
Re using her for containing other scps?
the example of
scp-956
Of overestimating the foundation's ability to control s cps with reality altering powers I
Would therefore like to make the following proposal a?
piercing implement will be constructed of
scp-144 Belov penetrating scp-239 s otherwise impenetrable skin
This tool will be used to kill
scp-239 while she is asleep and her powers are neutralized because of the danger of
Scp-239 awakening and resisting termination it is my recommendation that the selective operative carry
Scp-668 as well in order to minimize complications
One of the dangers of this procedure is the possibility that?
Scp-239 will awaken and perceive the operative as a friend or a quote good person in quote
Thus changing reality to match?
it is for this reason that I would like to volunteer to carry out the procedure personally a
Review of my personnel file should indicate that month should allow me to carry out the operation even after a reality shift of this nature
Clell
oh
Man dr. Clef is a weirdo
You